( music)
- OK, thank you.
I teach a course, Biology
101, and last Fall
it enrolled 220 students.
This big group of people here is as large
as many classes at Yale College,
these are just the
instructors for the course,
it's two professors
and 12 teaching fellows
and together we are grading and
providing feedback on 3,000 assignments
that the students hand
in during this course.
And this is logistically
daunting and we use Canvas
as our organizing tool
to get us through this.
One of the simplest things
that we use Canvas for
is to just distribute course
materials to the students.
So here in this Files
function, we've loaded up
a whole bunch of folders of materials,
so lecture notes for every lecture,
a study guide for every lecture,
all of the reading assignments.
Students just go in
here, download everything
electronically, there's
180 megabytes of materials
that students can
download in these folders.
I want to focus on our
homework assignments.
So students go into the Assignments tool,
they pull up a homework assignment,
they get information on it including
when it's due, the date and the time.
They click on this link,
they download the assignment
as an electronic document
and then they fill in
their answers to the
questions electronically.
They go to this screen,
they select the file
on their computer, they submit it
and that uploads the completed assignment.
And then our very favorite
feature for this class of Canvas
is SpeedGrader, which
was mentioned earlier.
So the teaching fellow goes in,
just gets a list of the
students in their section
whose work they're
grading, they don't need to
download the files for those assignments.
They just click on the
student and we get this
Preview window, which shows the contents
of that homework assignment.
And now, using these
tools, the teaching fellow
can go in and start
marking up the assignment,
they can write you got five
points on question one.
Here the student wrote something
that wasn't quite right,
the teaching fellow makes a note here
telling the student something.
At the end they can say
great work on this assignment
and then they fill in a score here
and that automatically goes
into the Grades function,
they click submit and they're done.
And I just want to emphasize
we never downloaded anything,
we never uploaded
anything and when you have
213 assignments to go through,
that's a huge time saving.
Those scores that we enter
automatically go into
the Grades function, which creates
this ginormous spreadsheet.
And I know you can't read the details,
but just to point out how this works,
every row is a student,
every column is an assignment
and then we've got a final
score here at the end.
And so here we're viewing all
the students in the course,
but a teaching fellow
could just pull up records
for the students in their section.
When we set this up at the beginning
of the semester, we assigned a point value
or a percentage value
for every assignment.
And then this system can
automatically take those values
into account and calculate a final score.
And we use a complex grading
scheme in this course,
so, for example, there are
five homework assignments
and the students are
allowed to drop the score
for their lowest scored
homework assignment.
And perhaps you can see here
in these first five columns,
for every student one of
the scores is grayed out,
and that's the one that
Canvas automatically
determined was the lowest score and
it got dropped from the final calculation.
We can see here the scores for
every student in the class.
The students, the
individual students can see
their own scores that we've entered.
And there's another function that we love,
so here's a detail from
the Grades feature.
We pull up specific
details about an assignment
and while we're entering
the scores and proofreading
and making sure we did
everything accurately
we mute the assignment,
so the students can't see
when we by mistake we
entered an incorrect score.
When we've determined that we've entered
everything correctly, we can
go in and unmute the assignment
and now, for the final
exam, all of the grades
are released to the
students at the same time.
When we have 3,000 scores
that we have to enter
we want to make sure we
don't make a mistake,
and because the students
can see their own scores
they make sure that we've
entered everything correctly.
We often communicate with
our students by e mail
and Canvas automatically interfaces
with the Registrar's computer.
So it makes these e mail lists,
here one for every student in the course,
so we can blast an email to everybody,
but also automatically
set up are e mail lists
for each one of the 13 sections,
discussion sections in the course.
So the teaching fellow leading a section
can click on one of those and communicate
just with the students in their section.
There's a new tool that
was beta tested this year
that we use called Sign Up that we use
to set up office hours
and we like that tool.
So here we are, I decide that I've got
three hours available tomorrow
when I could meet with students.
I go into Sign Up, I tell it
I'm available from 12 to three.
I decide that I'm going
to set up half hour
time slots so it divides it there.
I decide that I'm willing to see
one student at a time, so I set that up.
Now we have a little menu, I say OK.
Canvas automatically e
mails all the students
in the course and says
hey, Professor Koelle's
available from 12 to three tomorrow
and there's some new slots available.
They go in here, click on one of those,
that sets up an appointment.
There's then an itinerary
that I can see on Canvas
of all the students who are
coming at specific times
and they show up in my office.
We also use this to set up lunches,
I have lunch with a group of five students
at a time every Wednesday after lecture.
You can set up a slot here that lets
five students sign up for that time
and it takes care of all the logistics.
Large courses, they can be impersonal,
you'd like to be able to have one on one
interactions with the students
and this really facilitates that.
OK, thank you and I'll take questions.
(applause)
- [Audience Member] In the Sign Up section
are those slots blinded so
other students couldn't see?
- I believe so, so the student just sees
that a slot is available.
I can see who's coming, but they
can't see the other students.
- [Audience Member] You can choose that
as an option, though, if you wanted to
allow students to swap
spots, you have the choice
to determine whether or
not they will see it.
- [Audience Member] I have a question for,
not for you for the
technician, cause we used to
grade students homework, I, on Canvas,
but because he's reading Chinese,
so now for some reason this semester
we cannot see their responses, it's all
just boxes instead of caricatures.
Yeah, last year it worked
well, but this year
we cannot just grade it on Canvas
and we have to download
it and then upload, so.
- That sounds like a bug.
(laughs)
Send us an e mail at
Canvas@Yale and we can work with
because we have contacts at Instructure,
which is the company that created Canvas
and we can work with them to find out
why these things are going wrong.
So the more people who give us examples
of courses where this is failing,
the more they will have, you know,
something to dig into and research
to find out why this is
happening and fix it.
Any other questions?
All right.
(applause)
( music)